do you know why Ryan Gosling is so do
you know why Ryan Gosling is so hot I'll
tell you exactly why because he is like
he's he's not a pretty boy he's like not
he's not like super pretty looking but
he has like a present like a really like
suave presence and then he's like manly
but then yeah when do you see his face
he's like soft yeah and like it's just
like really sweet and it's like it's
like a sweet manly guy that you just
like he could really like you wanna do
we wanna [ __ ] him but then it's like you
want to like have him want like cuddle
with him on the couch because he's like
so cute and on top of all that so good
actor so it's like you're [ __ ] and
you've got talents like so rare these
days it just makes him even more hot
you're really making me want to watch
like a bunch of rock I don't know I'm
just imagining like I remember when I
first saw a drive that was one of the
greatest experiences on my life hands
down my favorite performance of all time
and I I really mean that because I just
relate so much with that character the
guys section at that time especially
like when I saw that movie for many
years I just feel like an emotionally
empty guy who had a lot of anger hidden
in it and i never expressed myself
mm-hmm but a girl or occasionally could
actually bring out something inside of
me and I found myself wanting to become
a protector of them so I was like
watching an an LA fantasy come to life
and what's so cool about Ryan Gosling is
he's a man mm-hmm you know he's a man
he's not he's not a pretty boy like I
thought he was before as the only movie
i saw of him before drive was in was the
notebook but i don't even think he's
like really a pretty boy in the mail
cookeville and even in remember the
titans that was my favorite performance
of him do you remember remember the
titans yes I'm if you close your eyes
you might just get a glimpse I
way into what he who he is and remember
the titans you look like he looked a lot
more boyish then oh yeah yeah he did
looks like you know like he wasn't super
manly and I mean I think after the
notebook he started getting like yeah it
didn't seem like you forced it you know
like the Caprio seemed like people were
like d DiCaprio's a queer and dicaprio
was like aw [ __ ] you guys i'm gonna do a
whole bunch of movies that make me look
straight and like a badass i totally
pulled it up I think he's one of the
coolest dudes yeah I still don't think
he's very attractive I'm not like Oh leo
but I don't I don't think he's like see
Ryan Gosling never seen totally never
lost that like sincerity yeah I don't
think he's at his ever he's ever being a
pretty boy because if you look like if
you look like at his face compared to
like the pretty boys I know like I don't
know who's a pretty boy Justin
Timberlake yeah Justin some really good
say is a pretty thick he's becoming a
man though like ya know every time he
does a good movie becomes more men I'm
just saying like he's been known as a
pretty boy but like their faces are more
symmetrical they tend to like their
auras like with Ryan Gosling like
technically speaking he has like his
nose isn't perfectly straight he's kind
of it's like kind of crooked his eyes
are closed set which is just a you know
it's normal i usually like most
beautiful people in the world having the
most symmetrical faces and so he has i
guess a little like imperfections at the
same time he's like really attractive
you know I mean and that's why I like
about him because he's like so
imperfectly perfect guy for real the guy
just always seems so comfortable with
himself he seems like this dude that
just truly is chill with who he has like
he seems he like he really accepts
himself and that's something that's kind
of admirable like you see how he just
walks and expresses himself it's like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah you know he
seems so damn relax like I said
swab he's just like cool I think the
average person has so much tension in
their shoulders that dude looks like he
gets a massage every other hour and he's
not a media [ __ ] too yeah that's
another thing I love about the guy's
head was cool too is you know like he's
not just a badass in all these movies
and stuff if you watch interviews with
him you love him even more yeah he's
like he's got this certain kind of
sarcasm about him that makes him that
much cooler and he could feel a certain
love that he has for just wanting to be
him and do what he wants to do you know
it's it's really it's a really it's
really cool of how he like doesn't give
a [ __ ] but it doesn't seem like it's a
front about it he's not like you know
like I don't give a [ __ ] you the other
thing I love about him is he seems like
he can do like any type of role yet it
seems real it doesn't seem like he's
having to go all out to judge fully
change the whole character who seems
like that person already existed within
him mm-hmm I feel like he does like he
is just being when he's in these
performances he's like so in the moment
it's amazing you know like he's like so
believable as everything he does I know
if s is everything yeah you know various
roles do you know I mean like I saw the
trailer for that new movie where he's
all like tatted-up and like oh you look
so cool that movie like he looks like he
does a really good job like I'm already
thinking like damn he's gonna rock and
then you see the trailer for Gangster
Squad you're like what a badass and then
you're like but he's so good as this
character in gangster squad 2 and
they're completely different characters
I feel like he's come a long way since
the notebook you know what dr really
showed that you could be a badass with
emotions he yeah because this guy is
like obviously really good-looking I
think how do you mean that in a homo you
know what I do mean homosexual way I
think okay the nice [ __ ] yeah I did you
I think if you your may
and you don't think Ryan Gosling is
good-looking something's wrong with you
yeah you can tonight and can I just say
in what was that movie we saw him with
Emma Stone what was that movie called it
wasn't love actually Crazy Stupid Love
easy Stephen love looking crazy stupid
love you see is be muscle holy [ __ ]
better oh you see Islam his love his lat
was Papa oh my god latter lots of tulle
or whatever is bad body was just like
bein like oh god damn it it's cuz I
remember I remember watching dr and
going this guy who got so much more buff
than i remembered and being notebook and
and then I you seen with his shirt off
and Crazy Stupid Love and you're like
[ __ ] third there's something about this
guy that I'm totally straight I know
this about myself but there's something
about him that makes me say stuff like
wow that guy's sexy but a weirdest [ __ ]
comes out of my mouth talking about him
you gotta give them the credit is there
good looking like I'm not lesbian in the
least but I think Meghan foxes she's
like gorgeous she's sexy gorgeous
everything you know you gotta give
credit where credit's due and just Ryan
Gosling is a fine piece of man it's not
just his looks and stuff that make him
appealing is a charm it's charges
charges energies it is his talent to
he's a super talented guy like when you
watch anything you're smart too yeah but
I want to finish my client on Iceland he
seems there's this movie now I'm almost
forgetting wait now I just remembered
we're not gonna say who did that but
anyway Ryan Gosling now if you watch
damning all his movie titles wrong I
keep confusing them with others
it's the one reason drug addict and he's
a high school teacher Half Nelson I
never seen okay well he's he's so good
at he got an Oscar nomination for it
he's like crazy good in it what is he
makes his he makes such relatable
performances it's so authentic yeah you
could always feel something like that's
what's great about him and drive like he
doesn't have that much to say but you
can feel so much without him having to
say much yeah you know you know you
don't need any backstory Ryan Gosling is
just feeling so much of whatever he's
feeling and word or feeling something
based off of that yeah and he's so good
and it's a powerful emotion feel like
he's really relatable like he reaches
your soul yes that's the key word soul
man Ryan Gosling reaches your soul what
are they gonna give him a freakin Oscar
he's totally deserves an awesome what's
he gonna release Aparna oh yeah I would
totally watch that I would buy them him
and hema stone did a porno that would be
perfect no when I don't think she's
attractive I think she looks like a bug
you know we're talking about Emma Stone
I think maggiore the time she looks like
a bud I think I think she's pretty
sometimes but for the most part she her
eyes just reminded me of like some thugs
like you're crazy give any idea when
Ryan Gosling would say to you if he did
you say that Ryan Gosling would probably
slap you and I would go good for you
ryan gosling with his [ __ ] hmm i've
never seen you this perverted before
that's what ryan gosling does to me